in the midst of the rubble a small boy
has spotted his head and arms covered in
blood
they don't even know if he's still alive
ed lips had far too many bloody Dame's
this was the bloodiest in three months
the rescuers weren't about to give up on
feminine cries of joy and relief he's
alive his name is Ahmed
and he doesn't know it yet but his
parents have both been killed in the
same bombing he's clinging on dazed and
hurt but he survived his sister is still
wedged under rubble
now the rescuers turned their attention
to her she seems unconscious but she too
has survived
they rush her off to what medical help
there is they're both now recovering in
intensive care
this was market day in maarat al-nouman
and many of the Dedham injured were
women and children among those who
witnessed this massacre was an American
Syrian teacher we talked to her hours
later via Skype we'll never forget the
moment where I was trying to jump over
the ruins so I can get him out and I
could not and then he ended up dying
that's why I said I couldn't think of
anybody else to call out except mr.
Trump because he's my present I can't
think of anybody stronger than him and
more capable than him to stop that's why
I was calling for him I should have
called for God I I don't know who we
call on anymore this is a marked
escalation in the crisis with intensive
airstrikes by Russian jets backing up
Syrian regime troops we witnessed
ourselves how the regime is targeting
journalists and civilians and the
Russians and Syrian regime is also
hitting hospitals another war crime
[Applause]
the area is dominated by militants once
linked to al-qaeda and multiple jihadist
groups but also millions of civilians
who've resisted the Syrian regime or
fled other areas which have been
attacked and it is they who are
suffering
Alex Crawford Sky News